the thing that deeply moves me about
cinema is to see 200 people in the mud
under the rain trying to create poetry
together i love that to be to surround
myself by people that are there because
they love cinema not because they love
themselves you know if you want to do it
with me unfortunately the only way i can
do it is my way i need time to make sure
that ideas
any ideas has deep roots inside me for
the first time i think i did this movie
for a single audience member which is me
we were teenagers we were dreaming big
you know we were very arrogant very
pretentious teenagers make sure that uh
i will not disappoint myself was not
easy because uh yeah
i i dreamt big you don't have a lot of
time to think on a set so the the the
all the meaning has to come from prep
the more i think artists are interesting
the more humble they are very often i
had time to
make sure that what we were doing was
will enjoy the best of time for me to do
as the best as you can do to stay intact
meaning protect your your integrity
protect your your identity
protect your identity stay yourself try
to be yourself and make no compromise
that's what i will say
the thing i love about cinema is
teamwork i love when people
i love to share creativity i love it the
thing that deeply moves me about cinema
is to see 200 people in the mud under
the rain trying to create poetry
together and and so much effort so much
uh
work uh for art it's that deeply touched
me i put a red tape on the floor i said
i don't want no nurse mad narcissistic
ego on this side okay no more seriously
there's people that have a bad
reputations
it's too tough to make a film it's too
difficult i prefer to work with um i
love
the more i think artists are interesting
the more humble they are very often like
someone like hugh jackman
roger dickens is a very very very humble
man you know but at the same time he's a
genius i mean i love to be to surround
myself by people that are there because
they love cinema not because they love
themselves you know it's like
two different things at the end of the
day technology or the the exotism of the
world of the world building it it's
something that is just there to uh
to uh receive as an impact and an impact
that will have a
an influence on on the inner journey of
the character and what i'm i'm
interested by is that it's that
introspective journey that that that
what that at the end of the day uh when
you make a
an exploration of a human condition or
some some
elements of uh
that will touch people in their their
their lives by meaning uh
the story of dune is relevant because it
has a
relevance in our human experience so
it's like uh uh
what i'm trying maybe i'm taking detour
right now to just see that
what it is the human journey that
interests me
yeah the the the science fiction what is
interesting is that it's a tool that
allows you to bring that human journey
and put it in a context where you're
totally free to express yourself about
more difficult subjects or more abrasive
subjects sometimes otherwise at the end
of the
very art of thing is it's the the
human experience and and that is
interesting the biggest challenge during
dune was by far
uh to deal and master with timothy's
hair no
because
it's it's it's alive and you guys don't
know okay sorry the the the the biggest
challenge i will say was to try to find
a balance between there's the the
the book is so rich and it's a book that
takes all its strength into its details
and
it was really to try to
to find an equilibrium
between the information that someone
that doesn't know the book at all the
the amount of information that the the
the this the audience that don't know
the book the the the amount of
information they will need to understand
the movie without
pressing them with exposition
and trying to be
of course
as cinematographic as possible so it's
like uh um
that was the the big challenge not
trying to
find the right
amount of information so the audience
could follow the story correctly and
follow this adventure we constructed
that chamber
in the tunnel it was a real set it
really created something sacred for the
actor they really felt that because of
the nature of the matter the colors the
lighting was so strong it was like a
massive
white screen one source of light that
was inspired by james turrell
installation and it was basically a
balinese theater you know you have that
big wide screen set what if i put just
silhouettes you know to add two
puppeteers with like long poles and with
like shapes to feel just that there's
nothing and suddenly
something appears like a dark shadow
that comes more and more strong and then
then float around and it was eerie
strange and beautiful even if it was
like very primitive it really helped the
actors
and most of the scene they were wearing
those huge asthmat suit and the only way
to communicate with them was with
microphones
so it was creating that they felt like
astronauts and i was very close i was
chatting in their ears all the time
describing them the scenes you know and
so it was like an interactive it felt
like an experimental installation for
the first time i think i did this movie
for a single audience member which is me
i discovered a book when i discovered i
started to get interested about
what is happening behind the camera what
is the job
or what the and
around the beginning of my team teams i
i really
got
obsessed with this idea of a smell of
being a filmmaker and doing a happened
almost in the same i read the book in
that period of time and what me and my
best friend at the time were dreaming
about movies being inspired by
great filmmakers and we uh we
we both together started to draw
what could be a doom
of course it was just fantasy it was
just like we were teenagers we were
dreaming big you know we were very
arrogant very pretentious teenagers and
when i landed and but that was uh
something that was out of reach for me
until i uh life is strange sometimes and
i never thought i would work in
hollywood but it happened and and
when you are in hollywood then you can
start being dream big that's the beauty
of that system and
when people were asking me what would be
one of your ultimate dream and the
answer was always doomed
it's it's um i had time to
make sure that what we were doing was
will enjoy the test of time for me
yeah
make sense for for the rest of my life
you know it's like uh it was a big
challenge for me and this one was to try
to please
that teenager that back then
and to make sure that i will not
disappoint myself it sounds weird to say
no it's not at all made this movie for
me
and for the massive dune family was i
was a freak franklin
and
make sure that
i will not disappoint myself was not
easy because uh yeah i i dreamt big how
did you get deacons
that is that is a
the answer is a i think is incredible
i got deacons because dickens wanted to
to work with me he's just a i met him at
the academy awards there was there's a
ceremony
before the
academy awards was called which is
called the scroll ceremony where they
take the five oscar uh nominee for best
foreign film and it's like 400 people
and then they they invite you there and
they there's just a nice ceremony where
one
filmmaker will take your film in front
of everybody and talk about the movie
why live love the movie and introduce
you to
the the family of filmmakers
like just a get-together cocktail but
it's a nice event it's very warm and
nice and the the person who introduced
something was roger deakins and he said
so much beautiful thing about about this
movie and um i remember that my
cinematographer andrei torpe was really
moved because
dickens was one of his hero and me i
couldn't believe it's because he's such
a master you know i'm
i was so impressed and so uh honored
that he uh he was uh willing to talk uh
in a good way about asante and and then
roger was curious about my work he went
and uh
saw my previous work
and asked his agent what is good guys
doing next and then he read prisoners
liked it loved it and said he asked his
agent to meet me so i was flying to
ellie to meet cinematographers and then
i received this phone call from my
producer and he said oh there's another
one we'd like to meet you his name is
roger deakins
so i had that serious i i was in a room
in a surrealistic
moment the most surrealistic moment of
my life
where i was in front of roger dickens
and he had he he was trying trying to
convince me
to work with him
i was like i thought it was the opposite
anyway the thing is that i think the
only way i was able to get to roger
dickens is because he was he wanted to
work with me otherwise
it would just stay a dream but i had
time
that's the thing about this movie is
that i had a nice time for to write and
to prep the movie and and make sure that
the
the world
is solid
and
very slow
i need time to make sure that ideas
any ideas and has deep roots inside me i
i don't like to
improvise new ideas on this and
understand this but i like when
talking about casting i'm talking about
design
and on the set i don't like to
intellectualize too much i mean it's
very important to go through all the the
ideas before
because it's very important because
cinema is a
a lot of about planning so you cannot
you
the more you plan the more you can
improvise but in order to to improvise
you have to be the ideas are to be very
clear in advance and so that's why with
other stimulographer production designer
everybody and all the actors all the the
intellectual uh discussion are in prep
after that on the set and we go to war
we shoot we don't have time to in a way
we have time
it's the time
you don't have a lot of time to think on
the set so the the the
all the meaning has to come from prep
i think
that
one of the key element
for attention
is that you need to bring
in the screen on the on the in the image
something that is the audience will
relate to
uh from a subconscious point of view
that an element that
will bring reality
can be light can be a plant it can be
something
that will make the shots
feel that like in a dream there's
something real there and light is very
strong for that that's why i loved roger
so much as that is and and the
the
this idea of bringing as much nature in
front of the camera as possible so your
brain
feels that's what you're about to see
could be real so how did you end up
doing prisoners how did you or
it's a very boring answer it's just i
read tons of scripts and
after polytechnic
a movie i made
two movies ago
i um
i reckon began to receive scripts from
hollywood and uh the polytechnic was not
a movie that was at a wide release but
that was was well received by other
filmmakers or agencies
producers denis i want to
ask you the last question
many of
us and i i know you've got some old uh
long-term friends here as well when many
of us would have grown up
alongside your films and seen you work
in independent films out of montreal and
then you know increase the scale and the
scope and the the the reach
of your movies is there anything that
you can say to people who who have that
kind of ambition
who may be working in small independent
films lower budget films but really want
to to get to the kind of
scale and scope that you're working at
now how did you do it and and what can
you say to people who are looking to do
that i asked this question once to
martin scorsese because uh before i went
to hollywood and he said to me
stay intact
try to
do do as as the best as you can do to
stay intact meaning protect your your
integrity protect your your identity
protect your identity stay yourselves
try to be yourself and make no
compromise that's what i would say
you